cryptozoo dot Co I am so excited about
this project it's it's it's so fun it's
a really fun game that makes you money
a fun game that earns you money how much
did you guys make from crypto zoo I lost
around fifty thousand dollars in cryptos
and I lost forty thousand dollars I lost
around 15 000 US dollars I lost twenty
five thousand dollars one hundred twenty
thousand dollars five hundred thousand
dollars Australian which is half a
million in crypto zoo shut up oh no you
haven't yeah 500k oh
today we're investigating Logan Paul's
crypto Zoo a blockchain game that made
Millions but never worked some of you
guys think you know the story but it
goes so much deeper I've uncovered
sociopaths billionaires fake orphans did
I mention fake orphans and of course at
the center of it we have Logan Paul
himself who has abandoned this thing
leaving thousands of fake orphans in his
wake wait a second
thousands of victims in his wake now
you'll be hearing from some of those
people because their stories are
heartbreaking this is the first in a
three-part series that's been a year in
the making and if you like high effort
investigations like this one please
consider supporting this channel on
patreon I don't take sponsors we are
viewer supported so if you want to and
are able to thank you either way enjoy
the video
for the last six months I've been
working on my own nft project we have a
massive team behind it and are probably
out of pocket like a million just
because we believe it's gonna work
September 1st cryptozoo.com we don't
scam I've never scammed anyone before
Logan cares extremely deeply about his
audience loves his audience loves his
brand doesn't have to scam to make money
[Music]
welcome to part one the million dollar
mystery that began this whole story like
many people I first heard about
cryptozoo from a podcast Logan runs
called impulsive which was the
experience of a lot of people that I
spoke to so I first heard about it on
the Logan Paul podcast impulsive I think
it was off the one of the impulsive
episodes the thing that I'm most excited
for and this is the first time I've ever
said anything about this for the last
six months I've been working on my own
nft project I think they need I think
there needs to be a fresh take in this
project that I have uh is that fresh
take now look at first I was just as
surprised that this pitch as anyone else
because I just got finished roasting
Logan for a different coin called dink
dink which is fans lost money on I'm a
big dog fan dumbest I've ever seen him
that's why I'm all In come on over take
pictures of my feet yeah it's comedic
it's fun it's comedy Now look I know
Logan and his friends tried to make it
look like dink dink was all about the
memes but it turns out they secretly
were tied to the project and Logan
created the dink toy character himself
and subsequently abandoned that project
so if you invested in it you got blasted
and Logan rightfully took a lot of heat
for dink doing which is why I was
surprised when he seemingly immediately
jumped into another crypto project but
Logan insisted cryptozoo it was
different it wasn't his friends project
this time it was his and it wasn't even
a project at all it was a game that
could earn you money I'm excited to
watch uh to watch my game you keep using
out and you just did it again and keep
using a word there
game
you're not using like a project it's a
game it's a game it's a fun it's a
really fun game that makes you money now
you might be wondering how is it
possible to earn money from a game well
let me try to break it down for you this
is how it was supposed to work you
started by buying this crypto token
called Zoo which is their in-game
currency and you use zoocoins to then
buy egg nfts which you can then hatch to
become animals you then can breed those
two animals to become hybrid animals for
example if you breed a gorilla and a
kitten you get a Gore Kitty and the more
rare the nft the higher the daily yield
of zoo tokens that animal earns you
every day theoretically it works like
almost like passive income you can then
burn your animal nfts to release the zoo
they earned back to you and from there
you can invest it into eggs or just cash
out now some of you of the Egyptian
persuasion might notice some triangular
qualities to this game description but
let's not be too quick to judge because
remember there are a lot of nft games
built on this model it's called play to
earn now Logan admits that there are
other games like his but what's going to
really make his stand out is that other
games have randomly generated assets his
game has handmade art it's quick to make
a digital asset with you know unique
randomly generated characteristics we
can made are for the past six months bro
approval very specific notes 10
different artists making art for our
project now I'll admit this all sounds
very enticing handmade art a fun game
that can earn you money and one of the
biggest influencers in the world backing
it you might think how can I lose which
is why when people were told all you had
to do to play was buy an egg people
spent Millions just on the first launch
between eth and Zoo people bought 2.5
million dollars worth of eggs in the
first day and did I mention the game had
hadn't even been launched yet all people
were buying was the marketing and the
promises and it wasn't just the nfts
they bought either the zoo token also
skyrocketed in value reaching a two
billion dollar market cap pre-game
launch right the trading volume was in
the tens of millions of dollars per day
which kind of is like fortnite not
coming out but people trading tens of
millions of dollars in V bucks every day
that's what this was like and I know it
sounds stupid to buy an influencer
project but you have to understand
people saw Logan as different it was
Logan Paul at the end of the day an
internet personality that I actually
trusted that I actually kind of believed
in obviously when someone so influential
releases something everyone wants to be
a part of it I still believe in this
false values that everyone else I
believe in that Logan Paul's a changed
man I thought it was a safe place having
a a guy like that identify like Logan
Paul being the head of the project they
had seen the story he had been telling
everyone that uh he was this reformed
influencer right that he was no longer a
reckless clout Goblin just in it for the
money they thought this time it's
different Logan Paul couldn't possibly
scam us
right but as the game got closer to
release the crypto Zoo team started
releasing the first ever photos of these
animals and come to find out this
handmade art story wasn't really true it
was actually Adobe stock photos mashed
together this was the sort of first red
flag of this project and I made a video
about it at the time um but it was kind
of surface level and something didn't
add up beneath the surface something
where I just couldn't shut this case
down in my head it was actually part of
the announcement video that they
something they said see if you can spot
it we have
a massive team behind it and are
probably out of pocket
like a million just because we believe
it's gonna work on development yeah
that's the line that started this whole
mystery we spent a million dollars on
development I couldn't get this out of
my head you know is he lying there's no
way he expects people to believe he
spent it on Art so wait maybe he spins
it on blockchain stuff right that's what
I thought but then I audited the smart
contract and it's not handmade at all
it's not even original it's what's
called a fork a copy of you know some
other code that exists out there one of
them is called flokey shib X which
launched before and so where'd this
million dollars go I I didn't understand
and Logan just kept repeating this claim
we put hundreds of thousands of dollars
in it uh personally the whole team a
million plus not the time I'm looking
into this there's a teaser going around
for hatch day which is the day you can
hatch your egg nfts and it kind of
symbolized the true launch of crypto so
I thought maybe this is it maybe this is
where they spent all the money on their
game even their community manager Ben
Roth promised people after hatch day
things will take a turn for the 180 so I
put Ben Roth on the board too I needed
to know all the characters in crypto zoo
and I waited and finally on November 3rd
2021 Ben Roth turned out to be right
things did take a turn on Hatch day only
for the worse let's meet one of the
victims helicopter Bob to explain more
my name is Rob helicopter Bob lost just
under seven thousand dollars with crypto
zoo and the first thing I asked Bob was
about his animals if he was making money
with kryptozoo how much he made and if
the passive yield worked oh it never did
from the beginning there it wasn't even
written into the contract where it
showed that you could that you were
actually yielding Zoom but there was
nothing that was actually you know
backing that up there was no way to
claim your yield whatever it was wait
wait play that again did you hear that
there was no way to claim your yield
there never was hold on the core
mechanic of cryptozoo that you can make
money with these stupid animals didn't
even work on launch day and still to
this day a year later still does not
work is what the investors are saying
which this is just crazy people spent
millions of dollars on these eggs but it
even gets worse because I kept talking
to people and I discovered something
because remember I told you you could
buy eggs with those Zoo coins well
apparently they also made it so you
could buy them with ethereum and on the
day of selling about half of these
purchases took place with ethereum only
it turns out for the people who spent
eth not only did the yield part of it
not work did the nfts not pay you you
also couldn't even hatch them so I have
acquired a bunch of eggs and and I
actually want to play the game I didn't
acquired the eggs with the intent of
keeping them I actually wanted to hatch
him and see what I got out of them and
play in this ecosystem that's been
advertised or whatever right and then I
can't do anything it's not showing up on
the website when I connect my wallet etc
etc so I'm a little baffled I'm like is
it I I must be doing something wrong so
I open up I open up a support ticket I
open up a support ticket with crypto
Zoom Ben Roth is actually the person
answering my support ticket oh yeah no
no it's it's down for the moment but
we're working on it let me tell you it's
it's it's never been it's never been up
wait you can't even hatch no do you see
I'm telling you it's just a picture
there's nothing I could do with it
you're kidding you can't hatch there's
nothing I could do with it you could ask
you could ask any of those Community
guys that's basically worth nothing
whatsoever wow so on launch day
basically nothing worked and a year
later that's still true now after this
was discovered the price of zoo fell 63
percent in just 24 hours and at this
point Logan Paul basically goes silent
on crypto no more podcast mentions no
more saying he handmade art cryptozoo
already got millions in Investments but
Logan only speaks in the Discord twice
over the next year to say quote sober
currently shaking my head and yo that
was his contribution to this project
meanwhile his community manager Ben Roth
was actively claiming that Logan was
going to be marketing cryptozoo any day
now he told people things like Logan is
controllable marketing Guru it's over
when we launch and when we have a
product to Market it'll get marketed and
marketing will crush I promise you and
this disconnect between Logan abandoning
the project and his team on cryptozoo
saying that he hadn't saying that it was
going to be any day now left investors
feeling like they were being led on all
you have to do was go on and tell us
look there's something going on with
this project I'm I'm abandoning it or
whatever before people got more and more
trucks and promising and promising yeah
this is going to be great but
when it came to actually doing anything
he just hid away from it have some
decency to come out talk to the people
that invested initially and invested
along the way on all of the fake and
false promises and all of the false hype
and be honest with people
because surely Logan Paul who's got this
billion dollar hydration company and the
WWE star is got enough money it doesn't
need to to Rook Isla and it's because of
these false promises about marketing
that these poor investors believed in
crypto Zoo so long they sat and watched
every Logan Paul episode trying to guess
and decipher when this so-called
marketing push would happen and Logan
and his team really fed into this with a
lot of cryptic messages only a month
after cryptos launch uh actually the
hatch day they started teasing this not
too much of this is out but he he's been
working on a massive project and the one
one of them will be the biggest thing I
ever do it'll be it's like my life in
Seoul is put into this project which is
where most of my time these days goes
wow surely this secret project that
Logan put his soul into is crypto Zoo
right you know the project he launched a
month ago well his fans certainly
thought so I'm like holy cow makes so
much sense he's talking my cryptozo Ben
and the dudes are like like putting
smiley faces and egging the rest of the
community like this is it guys you know
this is what we've been working towards
I mean this is it this this is this it's
finally happening Logan's gonna Market
the project and they kept saying that
Logan's gonna Market the project and
it's going to change everything
so now imagine their surprise when
another clip surfaces of Logan finally
admitting this secret project isn't
cryptozoo at all it's something else
entirely I'll tell you about this
project when uh we get closer to launch
this project is that the thing about the
egg no no no okay this one this one this
one's gonna be it yeah this has been
crazy I've ever done oh man can you
imagine if you're one of these investors
and Logan Paul's going pitching this new
secret project and you're thinking it's
crypto zoo and someone's like oh is it
that is it that thing with the eggs and
he's like no no no no definitely
definitely not that was the last project
this is the real project that I'm
working on thankfully people didn't just
let this slide because as he went around
making the rounds on his new project
called 99 Originals people were like hey
didn't you just abandon your last one
and unsurprisingly it's not his fault
it's the Bad actors who ruined the
project as I see people giving multiple
explanations for why these haven't
worked and you know there's accusations
out there how does it make you feel when
people are doing these takedown videos
about your nft projects previously uh
it's it's sad because of what I just
said there's so much going on behind the
scenes like [ __ ] I'm not the bad guy
here yeah yeah there's some actual out
there yeah and it's not me like I'm here
to build this is a space where a lot of
people do see dollar signs like any
burgeoning industry if there's money to
be made there's going to be both good
and bad people
um there's a lot of shaped characters in
The crypto space I'm learning all of it
we had an issue with um crypto Zoo where
our our lead developer uh took the code
that he made fled to Switzerland
actually fled to Switzerland and like
held it hostage for a million dollars
like behind the scenes drama that like
like took uh took a stick and stuck it
in the spokes of my wheels oh well that
wasn't expected there's a shady
developer who held up Logan's code
hostage in Switzerland that's why this
hasn't worked the whole time he held it
to hostage for a million dollars well
let's add that to the board I mean isn't
the mystery solved now obviously the
first thing I wanted to do was hunt down
this developer who will be calling Z
here and find out the truth of what
happened
why did he steal Logan's code for a
million dollars however I finally got a
hold of him and when I did he admitted
he took the code hostage but he says the
reason for it was nothing like what
Logan had said
anything
anything
[Music]
a week on building this building this
thing
and the only thing they brought to the
table were a bunch of Photoshop so Z
claims he wasn't blackmailing anyone he
had to hire a team to develop this whole
thing and he just wanted to be paid for
the work they did according to him they
negotiated a one Million Dollar Payday
for this whole project and from the
second I heard that I thought oh that's
interesting because Logan claims he
spent a million dollars on this whole
thing and this developer saying he's
owed a million dollars on this project
now I didn't want to just take one
person's word for it so I later
confirmed with another developer who
worked for something called the
blockchain center that he also hadn't
been paid uh we've been paid nothing I
would have loved to have Zoo but I don't
have any so that's multiple sources
working on the crypto Zoo team project
who were not paid now obviously these
are Big accusations which is why I
wanted to confront Logan Paul on them
but unfortunately we're not exactly on
speaking terms so I wondered how could I
speak to Logan without speaking to Logan
and that's when I found out there was
someone who might know Justice as much
about this whole story and I will
explain everything one day with my
manager who's like
in charge now Logan Paul's manager a guy
named Jeff Levin he might be just what
we need to settle this whole thing so I
gave him a call
hello hey Jeff hey uh sorry to bother
you this is Stephen with coffee Zilla
I'm calling because I've heard reports
that crypto Zoo hasn't paid their
development team and I'm just reaching
out for comment before I do this story
um I got your number from one of the
development team and they just wanted to
I just want to follow up on that
um I have no comment for it
okay you're are you guys denying it are
you saying it's not true
it's no common I don't think that the
information is true okay because they're
saying a million dollars hasn't been
paid in development for crypto Zoo
and Logan Paul said publicly that it has
been paid
um so I mean it's pretty serious
accusation and obviously I don't want to
just run a story if you guys have a
whole side to another story here your
job your job as a as a
um
as someone that is reporting news
is to actually verify correct news right
that's why I'm calling you
I know and that's legal
grounds for that stuff
so I'm just telling you
legally
you have to report correct news with a
verifiable information right that's why
I'm calling you they've given me a lot
of things
a lot of evidence okay well
okay you can you can have the evidence
you want but I'm just letting you know
if you report anything on us I
appreciate your business I appreciate
you as a person and I'm just telling you
you know from a legal standpoint
as we've been advised always is if
anybody reports fake news
that's where we won't you know yeah this
call was a mess Jeff Logan's manager
seems to be implying that I'm not
allowed to repeat allegations his own
development team made even though Logan
can go on podcasts and publicly accuse
those developers of stealing his code
not only that he's the one who refuses
to provide any evidence but seems to
sort of be implying that maybe we'll sue
you if you tell this to anyone which he
then denies doing when I ask him if
that's what he's doing told you I have
no comment to it telling you once again
from a legal standpoint you have to
report truth if you do not verify truce
then you're just allegations and those
then will be
handle the way that we want to handle it
wait so you're saying you're saying you
refuse to give me proof that the
allegations aren't true but if I report
on the allegations you guys might Sue no
no I did not say that I did not say that
I I I'm just I'm trying to read between
the lines
don't read between the lines okay listen
exact words that I'm saying okay so the
exact words I'm saying I'm listening I
have no comment on the situation okay
your job legally is to report facts if
you don't report facts
on the information you're given it is
illegal yes that was a real conversation
with a real person now I'm no lawyer but
I don't think it's a crime to say that
multiple developers say they haven't
been paid and Logan's team refuses to
provide any evidence or like statements
or wire transfers that they have which
by the way seems incredibly ironic given
just how much Logan whines about not
being paid by Floyd Mayweather where's
my money [ __ ] Floyd never paid me for
our fight who am I the IRS nope but you
might be the crypto Zoo Dev team now in
all seriousness I do want to acknowledge
something which actually kind of looks
bad a bit on the developers because it
turns out very few written contracts
were actually done so much of this were
verbal deals like oh we'll take care of
you we'll give you 350k we'll give you a
million we'll give you whatever but then
when it was time to actually sign the
deals there's just always delays what
kind of promises were made to you
uh verbal promises basically so uh
verbal promises and then we follow up
with like a physical paper agreement but
that's when communication broke down
this is where I think the dev guys
screwed up and led to this whole
situation of like okay we're just gonna
take the code private until you pay us
for our work and to be clear I'm not
justifying not paying someone for what
they did I'm just playing Devil's
Advocate and saying this could have all
been avoided by just getting every
detail in writing and I think it's just
a good General lesson but if you're
thinking that that's the million dollar
mystery solved well no because this
still doesn't make sense why not just
pay the dev team what you publicly said
you kind of already paid them why not
pay for a game that now isn't launched
and now investors are so angry about why
not pay when you already made Millions
from minting the eggs on this game well
this is where things get even stranger
because right when I was ready to pin
every everything on Logan and believe me
he is at fault I was speaking to the Z
developer and I heard a name that I
hadn't heard before
and a million dollars never you never
really never paid me wait a second who's
Eddie I thought that all of this was
Logan Paul I only put it together when
the blockchain center guys also said a
similar thing about their deal they said
they were promised 350k and it was
Ibanez they say they had no
Communications with Logan but we know
they weren't talking about different
people they both dealt with the same guy
so the guy's name I put it together must
be Eddie Ibanez turns out he was
managing the developers what's this
random guy doing in Logan Paul's project
and who is he who is Eddie ivanus
yes hi my name is Eddie ivanized lead
developer here at crypto Zoo this
reporter says Eddie's entire story is
fake
continuously lie lead people on hype
people up to put more money in all all
the while in the background things are
going down things are hitting the fan
and you've left us holding the bag Logan
you stole 40 million in tokens from me
you are a scam artist you are a liar and
you betrayed your own Community you
aren't that guy Logan replies oh trust
me bro I am that guy
[Music]